COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. IN RESPONSE TO THE COVID
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE
TORS AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS.
HANDED HERE THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. TWO
TWO TWO THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE WEBSITE OR
THIS COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. YES
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED. AND YOU WILL BE READY
TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST. MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE. DUE TO. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY EACH
SIDE WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL BE THE ONE
MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO S DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS. MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
INTO CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IT IS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS. WHO
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES. MAY BE
HEARD. WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA THEREFORE
MEASURES PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SO WE BUILT TWO
EIGHT SEVEN. I DON'T KNOW HER
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THREE
FIVE ITEM NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR EIGHT FOUR AND ITEM
NUMBER TEN. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
THREE ZERO. WE WILL WAIT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT WE WILL
PROCEED- AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
TODAY. TO THOSE LISTENING
NORMALLY WE FOLLOWING FILE
ORDER HOWEVER IN ORDER TO MOVE
THE PROCEEDINGS ALONG WITH
MEMBERS OR DELAYED IN OTHER
PROCEEDINGS OTHER COMMITTEES OR
OTHERWISE WE WILL TAKE ITEMS
OUT OF FILE ORDER IF WE HAVE
MEMBERS HERE. WHO ARE WILLING
AND ABLE TO PRESENT- DOCTOR
WOULD I SEE THAT YOU WERE THE
FIRST TO ARRIVE SO WHY DON'T WE
TAKE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN. THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THREE PRIMARY ISSUES NUMBER ONE
ASSURING THE AVAILABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. OF NEW CANNABIS
CANNABINOID RELATED DRUGS AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE FOR
MARKET FOLLOWING FDA APPROVAL
AND SUBSEQUENT RESCHEDULING
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY ADOPTED THE SCHEDULING
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS CONTAINING
CONNECT CANNABIDIOL CANNABIDIOL
THAT'S A HARD WORD SORRY SORRY
ABOUT THAT- THERE- THEREBY
ALLOWING FDA APPROVED THERAPIES
TO BE AVAILABLE. HOWEVER
SEVERAL OTHER CANNABIS DERIVED
MEDICINES THAT CONTAIN
CANNABINOIDS ARE UNDER
DEVELOPMENT AND ENTERING THE
FDA APPROVAL PROCESS. THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT THESE DRUGS
ONCE FDA APPROVED WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIANS
SUFFERING FROM SUCH
DEBILITATING DISEASES AS WELL
AS- FOR EXAMPLE MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS. THE SECOND ISSUE
WITHOUT FURTHER ALIGN FEDERAL
LAW WITH CALIFORNIA LAW TO
EXEMPT FROM SCHEDULING
COMBINATION DRUGS WHERE THE
RATIO OF CONTROLLED DRUG
COMPONENT TO THE NON CONTROLLED
INGREDIENTS. QUALIFIES THE DRUG
PRODUCT FOR THE EXEMPTION. THE
LACK OF CONSISTENCY BETWEEN
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW FOR THE
SPECIFIC DRUG COMPOUNDS CREATES
CONFUSIONS FOR PHARMACISTS
PRESCRIBERS AND THE BOARD TO
REGULATE THEM. THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF PHARMACY HAS REQUESTED
THIS CHANGE TO PROVIDE CLARITY
AND CONSISTENCY. AND THIRDLY
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION
REMAINS IN THE GRIPS OF A
NATIONAL PANDEMIC. THAT OF DRUG
USE AND OVERDOSE DEATHS. AS A
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL I
FULLY SUPPORT THE FUNDAMENTAL
NEED TO ENSURE THE PRIVACY AND
SECURITY OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
IDENTIFIABLE DATA. PARTICULARLY
WITH RESPECT TO SENSITIVE
MEDICAL INFORMATION SUCH AS
CONTROLLED CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
USE. IT'S IMPORTANT STATE
STRATEGIES ADOPTABLE SEASON
PRACTICES TO PREVENT
UNAUTHORIZED UNNECESSARY USE OF
RELEASE OF THIS INFORMATION.
HOWEVER AS A SCIENTIST I ALSO
SUPPORT THE ABILITY BUT
INABILITY OF BONA FIDE
RESEARCHERS TO CONDUCT
MEANINGFUL RESEARCH. RECENT
REGULATIONS ADOPTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE SEVERELY
HINDER RESEARCH ACCESS TO
STATEWIDE CURES DATA. AND IT
AFFECTS STIFLE OR EVEN WHOLE
POPULATION. LEVEL PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY REESE SIR INTENT TO
END. OUR INTEREST. OF THE ISSUE
SURROUNDING DRY USE TO DEVELOP
DATA SO FOR RISK DRUG. I AND OF.
A. B. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WERE
RESTORE ONLY TO THE USE SYSTEM
M. THEY'RE GOING TO FIGHT READ.
ACCESS SECURES AND THE REQUIRED.
THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO THE NEW
REGULATIONS. I HAD TO WIN
ASSISTANCE- HERE AND SUPPORT
THIS MORNING- AND SORT OF RAN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER FOR PHARMACY.
AND SEVERAL HATCHET SERRA HOW
CHILL WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE PROCEED.
TOTAL MORNING SHARE. PLEASE
PROCEED. IN ORDER TO CARE FOR
THEIR EFFORTS IN ROCK THANK YOU
KAREN LANDED THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE CALIFORNIA
REPORTER PHARMACY SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
INCLUDE CONTENT PROVISIONS
REPORTED FEEDING YOU A LINE
CALIFORNIA SCHEDULE WITH THE
FEDERAL CONTROLLED COMPUTER
SCHEDULED FOR SPECIFIED NON
CONTAINING COMPANY PRODUCT I
DIDN'T KNOW LETTER TO THE BOARD
IS SEEKING CHANGE AT THE DISK
CAN. CREATE IN- LICENSES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING ROCK AND THEN THAT
IS SERRA WITH THE UNIT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO THANK
THEM MEMBER WOULD FOR INCLUDING
YOU SEE AN EIGHT FIVE SEVEN
WE'VE THANK FOR USED AXE TO THE-
WITH A THREE MANNER. THANK YOU
FOR TAKES SERIOUSLY OUR COMMIT
TO THIS RESEARCH FOR
MAINTAINING PRIVATE SECURE AND
HUMAN SUBJECTS REQUIRED BY LAW
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM ANYONE
AND GALLERY SUPPORT- IS NO WAY.
ARE THERE ANYWAY IN ROOM ONE
TWO WHICH TESTIFY IN SOME OF A
SIM BILL TWENTY SO. I SEE NO
WITNESS THERE WILL MOVE TO WIN
WAIT TO TEST VIA TUCKER. ORVIS
MODERATOR YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TESTIFY IN SOME. OF
ASSEMBLY BY FIVE SO WE WERE
BEGIN. THANK YOU IN THE
REMINDER. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
FOR A QUESTION OR COMMENT
YOU'LL HEAR AN INDICATION
YOU'VE BEEN PLACED IN THE QUEUE
AND MAY REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
THE QUEUE BY REPEATING THE ONE
THEN ZERO COMMAND. WE WILL
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER AND
THEN IN EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
WILL OPEN UP YOUR MIND AT THAT
TIME. YOU. GO TO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK
YOU. COURTS RECORD. GREATER
FIRED. INSTITUTE OF. IN THE
PORTION OF THE BILL RELATED TO.
CANNABIS NOISE MEDICATION.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER LINE DIDN'T YOU.
THANK YOU- MISS MODERATOR.
LET'S NOT FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION FIRST IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
SEEING NO SUCH WITNESSES. BUT
SOME OF THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
MISSED MODERATOR FEW WOULD ONCE
AGAIN PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WILL MOVE UP
WILL MOVE FORWARD. IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN SHOOTING UP. GREAT
LET'S NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE CHAMBER SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MR- DOGWOOD THANKS
FOR BRING THIS BILL I'M GLAD
TO. MAKE THE MOTION- IF AND
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU SENATOR HOLLINGS ANY OTHER
OR FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS. SEEING NONE. DR
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS WHEN YOU HAVE CORN
SYRUP. THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR NEWMAN THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD THE MOTIONIS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY BUT
FIRST. LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
RALPH NADER RALPH HERE
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
HERE PLEASE BEATS HERE BACKER
DAUGHTER EIGHT MEN EIGHT MEN
HERE HER TADO. JONES LLEVA
MAIN. MENU HERE NEWMAN NEW MEN
HERE AND SHOW A BOGUS. THAT
SHOW ABODE HERE PAN HERE AND
HERE. FILE ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY
FIVE TO SEVEN WORD DO YOU PASS
AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
RALPH HI RALPH HI MELINDA.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BEATS
HI THE FIVE BACKERS. DODD ADMIN
HI EIGHT MEN I HEARD. JONES
LLEVA MAN I MEAN I KNEW MAN HI
NEWMAN I A SHOW ABOUT OKAY HI
AND SHOW A BOGO HI P. N. HI CAN
I. BILL IS EIGHT VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU DEFINITELY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. YEAH
DEFINITELY THE MAJORITY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL IN THE- KILL.
CONSENTS FIRELIGHT I'M ONE
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM FOR A. B. FOUR THREE FIVE
FILE ITEM. SIX EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHT FOUR FILE ITEM. TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY. WE DO NEED
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THERE ARE TWO OTHER
MOVES THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI PROF
HI MELINDA IS ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I'D BE FINE BEAT FIVE
BACKER DIED EGGMAN. HER TADO.
HER TADO I'D JONES. LLEVA MAIN
MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I IT SHOW
A BOGUS HI A SHOW ABOUT IPN.
CAN I. THAT'S ABLE TO HOLD ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. LET'S-
THAT'S RUPERT'S MOVED TO A
SEVEN MEMBER CHEN ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHO IS HERE IN THE
CHAMBER ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE
FIFTY SIX. SO REMEMBER WELCOME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
TIME AND MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT EIGHT THREE FIVE
SIX THIS BILL WOULD GRANT
PHYSICIANS SURGEONS AND DOCTORS
OF PODIATRIC MEDICINE REVIEWS
POROSITY IN ANOTHER STATE. ONE
TIME TEMPORARY PERMIT TO USE
FOR OSCAR P. X. RAY EQUIPMENT.
FOR THE SURGEON WAS FOR THE
PERMANENT CERTIFICATION THIS
BILL WOULD ENABLE THEM TO USE
CROSS THREE FOR UP TO TWELVE
MONTHS. SINCE CALIFORNIA
CERTIFICATION PROCESS IS UNIQUE
ONE OUT OF SIX SURGEONS COME TO
THE STATE THEY OFTEN DO NOT
PARTICIPATE AND ANTICIPATE THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FEROCITY
CERTIFICATION. THIS
CERTIFICATION PROCESS IS
OUTDATED AND CAN TAKE UP TO SIX
TO NINE MONTHS TO OBTAIN
THROUGH PHYSICAL APPLICATIONS
DURING THAT TIME THE SURGEON IS
ABLE TO OPERATE FROST B. X. RAY
EQUIPMENT. AND SURGERY TO HELP
THEIR PATIENTS EIGHTY THREE
FIVE SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE
ACCOUNT FOR DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE A SURGEON
AND ONE TIME NON RENEWABLE
TEMPORARY PERMIT TO OPERATE.
FOR US THREE X. RAY EQUIPMENT.
TO TODAY WITH ME IS STONE
RIPPER THE CAL. ASSOCIATION AND
RYAN SPENCER. REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA DIET TRICK MEDICAL
SOCIAL. PLEASE PRESS MISTO. I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH JIM IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIBER OR KEEP INSTITUTE WOULD
LIKE TO SAY OUR THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE MEMBER- THE OTHER
WOULD BE ABOUT BILL WELL. SINCE
CAL IS ONE OF ONLY TWO STATES
REQUIRING PHYSICIANS TO HAVE
THE DEATH CERTIFICATESAND WENT
OUT OF STATE DR HERE THEY DON'T
KNOW THEY NEED TO DO TO GET
THIS OFFER TO THE ANN AND THAT
LENGTHY PROCESS REALLY RENDERS
THEM UNABLE TO USE PROPERTY
WHICH IS THE VIDEO X. RAY THAT
IS BURIED NOW IN THIRD GRADE
MAKE SURE THAT THE PERSON BELOW
ON THE PHONE. FOR THEY YOU BACK
AND SEND ON YOUR WAY- WHERE. ON
STILL AND- YOU'RE EITHER THINK.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THE
CHAIR INSTEAD ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNT PODIA ETTRICK SO THERE
THE CODES OF THE BILL WITH THE
SO SHE'S IN THE INTEREST OF OUT
SIMPLY LIE ICON WITH PREVIOUS
SPEAKER STONE THE ENTERTAINMENT
CHANNEL JUST MAKE MY AVAILABLE
PROTECTOR QUESTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. THAT'S TRUE
ATTENTION TO WITNESS IN THE-
AND SUPPORT. I SEE NO SO
WITNESS. OR THE ANY WITNESS IN
ROOM ONE TWO WHICH TESTIFY IN
SOME. OF A SIM BILL. READ SIX
SEEING NO WAY. LET'S TO WIN.
WHO TO TESTIFY IN SOME VIA
TELECOM OVER. MODERATOR YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- THE SIMPLE BILL THREE
FIVE SIX WILL BEGIN. IF YOU ARE
ARGUABLY YOUR SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIVE SIX PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE TO RING UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY AND OPPOSITION.
SAYING NO SUCH WITNESSES ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIVE SIX.
SEEING NONE. THAT'S MOVED
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORBIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD. AGAIN
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL BEGIN. AND
IF YOU'RE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MATURE WE HAVE NO
INJURING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER FIRST
OF SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- QUESTIONS FOR-
YOU KNOW THE WITNESSES ARE FOR
THE AUTHOR- THE END OF FREE
SHEET- WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM ALTHOUGH I'D
SAY THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM
REALLY IS THE LENGTH OF TIME
CITY TEACH. TAKES ISSUE THE
PERMIT AND- AND I GUESS THEY
JUST THAT THE BILL HAS TO HAVE
THIS. BUT PERHAPS YOU HAVE
CALLING ON C. T. JUST- FOR OUT
HOW TO MAKE IT MOVES OUT. BUT I
DID HAVE QUIT. MORE SPECIFIC TO
THE BILL ONE IS THAT I
UNDERSTAND ONE REQUIREMENTS IS
THAT THE- THE- THE POSITION OR
THE UP. MARKET TODAY TOOK
MEDICINE. HAS USED FOR OSCAR P.
AND ANOTHER STATE SO QUESTION
NUMBER ONE IS HOW DO THEY
CERTIFY THAT DID THEY HAVE TO
HAVE A CERTIFICATION OR
SOMETHING SO. SO DOES THIS
DEFINITION IS USED FOR US IN
ANOTHER STATE BECAUSE THEY JUST
USE IT A COUPLE TIMES IS THAT
ENOUGH SO JUST WHAT STANDARD IS
THAT. AND IN THE SECOND ONE IS
THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S MENTIONED
IT TAKES SIX TO NINE MONTHS TO
ATTAIN THIS CERTIFICATION IF
THE PERSON DOESN'T OBTAIN THE
CERTIFICATION- ORTIZ FAILED THE
CERTIFICATION- EFFORT- SHOULD
WE STILL CAN. ALLOW HIM TO.
CONTINUE TO USE FOR OSCAR P.
FOR ANOTHER THREE. OR UNTIL TE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR. WHEN IF
THERE ARE SOME. LACE WHERE SO
HAS TO COME. ABOUT THEIR-
ABILITY TO APPROACH TO THE USE
FOR OSCAR P. SO- SHOULD APPEAR
TO TIME REALLY BE UP TO WELL.
INTO THE OFFICE IS THAT THE
CREATURE. BY THE FACT THAT YOU
DIDN'T PASS CERTIFICATION- THAT
THAT WOULD BE THE TIME WHICH
THAT PERMIT WOULD CEASE- VERSUS
A YEAR OR A YEAR AT. MAXIMUM
SO. I GUESS THOSE ARE TWO
QUESTIONS. I HAD SPECIFIC TO
YOUR BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PANEL FOR THE FRIDAY.
THE KNOWLEDGE OF DEFERRED
ACTION. THE YEAH I THINK IT'S A
MUCH CAN DOWN SO- THE A GREAT
STAR HAND FIRST OF ALL THE
ABOUT HOW. THE TIME LIKE TO
HELP NOTE THAT THE DOCTOR HAD
FAR BE ANY OTHER STATE IN APP
EIGHT OF FORMAL AFTER ADMIT
THEY BE THEY WOULD- YOU KNOW
THEM OUT BECAUSE THE OTHER DAY
TO LOOK ANY A THIRD THERE ISN'T
A WHOLE WAY- YOU KNOW THE
DOCTOR THAT OTHER THAN THAT
AND- THAN THE DOCTOR AT HIM OR
HERSELF I. AND THEN FOR THE
SECOND ONE YOU'RE RIGHT PEOPLE
A ONE TIME PERMIT SO WHEN THEY
TAKE THAT PATH TO GET THE RATE
CERTIFICATION- THERE AFTER THAT
IF THEY TO PASS THAT PERMIT
WOULD KNOW LONG. BE IN THE FACT
THAT WITH ONE ON- THEY TAKE THE
CAT TO GET THE PERMIT FOR THE
REGULAR PROCESS AND THAT. YOU
KNOW IT'S SORT OF A LOOTED BUT
YOUR PREVIOUS COMMENT IN ORDER
TO TAKE THE CAT. YOU RIGHT OKAY
YOU FIND THE DATE ON THE CAT
THE TICKET IF THEY CAN TAKE A
LONG TIME. BUT IF YOU TAKE THE
TEST RIGHT AWAY IF YOU'RE LUCKY
AND YOU GET THE CAP AFTER THREE
MONTHS THEN YOUR PERMITWOULD
ONLY LAST FOR THREE MONTHS.
UNTIL YOU GOT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
TO DO THE CLARIFY THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGES IS THAT. UP TO A YEAR
BUT THEN ONLY IF YOU. PASS THE
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU PRACTICE YOU
FAIL THE TESTED. REMITTANCE
TERMINATE RIGHT THAT'S THE
ENDPOINT. OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT
THAT'S THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
YEAH. AND THEN YOU SEE YOU YOU
DID MENTION AN ATTESTATION THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN TRAINED OR HAVE
HAD SOME. SORT OF EDUCATION AND
FOR US TO BE. YEAH IT WILL FACT
THE NEWS DIDN'T CRACK. IT WOULD
BE A GOOD FIT THAT OKAY ALL
RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S THE
AWFUL. THANK YOU DR CALLING ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS SENATOR BATES THE MAIL.
SERVICE IS MOVE THE BILLS MUST
REMEMBER CHEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECT ME ANSWERING
PHONES PERFECT CAN THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR BATES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IS I'D
LIKE TO REMIND YOU TO PLEASE
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE ON. AB
THREE FIVE SIX FIVE ITEM THREE
D. POSSUM REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RALPH HI. RALPH HI MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA HI URGE A LOT I.
BEATS HI. B. R. I. BACKER.
BACKER I'D DODD. HEY MAN HER
TADO FURTADO I'D JONES LEYVA
MIN FIVE MIN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN
I A SHOW ABOUT OKAY I'M A SHOW
ABOUT I. P. N. P. N. I. BILL IS
NINE VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU FOR REMEMBERS.
LET'S MOVE TO- LET'S TAKE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
ZERO ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
MORNING THANK YOU I WANT TO
START BY THANKING GENERAL THING
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND I WANT
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS WHICH
ALLOW SUFFICIENT TIME FOR THE
BUREAU TO DEVELOP NECESSARY
REGULATIONS. REQUIRED FOR NEW
LICENSURE PROGRAM. EIGHTY FIVE
OH ONE WILL PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL OPTION FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THAT IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY AND
GIVES ANOTHER CHOICE FOR
BURIAL. THE MEASURE WOULD ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ORGANICALLY
BECOME POLLS ALSO REFERRED TO
AS THE REDUCTION IN HUMAN
REMAINS. AFTER IS THAT YOUR
PROCESS IS COMPLETE FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES OF THE SEASON I
INTEGRATE THE REMAINS OF SOIL
WHEN PLANTING A TREE OR GARDEN
IN REMEMBRANCE OF THEIR LOVED
ONES. CURRENTLY THERE ARE A FEW
REAL OPTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS COMMON OPTIONS
INCLUDE TRADITIONAL BURIAL
WHICH COUNTIES CHEMICALS WHEN
THE TREATED WOOD AND THE
EMBALMING PROCESS FROM THE
GROUND. AND CREMATION WHICH
ACCOUNTS FOR OVER 66% OF AFTER
THAT CHOICES. IN CALIFORNIA AND
EMIT CO TWO INTO THE ATMOSPHERE
POLLUTING AIR. AND CONTRIBUTING
TO CLIMATE CHANGE. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT THE
CONVENTIONAL VERY INTIMATE
INFORMATION ARE PROFOUND IN THE
UNITED STATES CEMETERIES TAKE
UP ONE MILLION ACRES OF LAND.
AND CAVITIES FOUR MILLION ACRES
OF FOREST EVERY YEAR. THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT-
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
ON THE PHONE I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. YOUR WITNESSES MAY
PROCEED HELLO. HI THIS IS KATE
AND GERRY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE I AM A
FUNERAL DIRECTOR AND FUNERAL
HOME OWNER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GIVING MY FULL
SUPPORT THE BILL THIS PAST YEAR
FUNERAL DIRECTING HAS BEEN A
TOUGH BUSINESS THE PANDEMIC
CAUSED EXTREME BACKUPS WITH
CREMATORY RUNNING TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY AND BURIAL NOT
HAPPENING FOR MONTHS WE REALLY
COULD HAVE DESPERATELY USED
ADDITIONAL METHODS. OF BODY
PROTECTION. NOT ONLY IS NATURAL
ORGANIC PRODUCTION ANOTHER
OPTION FOR OUR FAMILIES IT'S AN
OPTION THAT FOR MANY IS MORE IN
LINE WITH THEIR RELIGIOUS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES. THE
MAJORITY OF MY CLIENTS AND
CALIFORNIANS IN GENERAL ARE
CREMATED AT THE CREMATION
DOESN'T WORK FOR EVERYONE. AND
INTRODUCING NATURAL ORGANIC
PRODUCTION ISN'T AN OPTION IS
GOING TO CREATE A CALMER
CLEANER MORE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE FOR MY FAMILY AND
PERHAPS EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY.
IT WILL BE LESS EXPENSIVE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES BUT IN
TRADITIONAL BURIAL I THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
PLEASE. HELLO THIS IS KATRINA
STATE. I'M FOUNDER AND CEO OF
RECOMPOSED PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING NATURAL ORGANIC
PRODUCTION THANK YOU TO OUR
BILL FOSTERED AND SUPPORTED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
BRINGING NEW END OF LIFE
OPTIONS TO YOUR STATE. IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN I LEARNED
ABOUT DECADES OF RESEARCH
AROUND THE PROCESS OF LIVESTOCK
<c.magenta>ORTALITY COMPOSTING ATTRACTED</c>
BY FARMERS ALL OVER THE UNITED
STATES. THE PROCESS IS SIMPLE A
BODY IS COVERED IN NATURAL
MATERIALS LIKE STRAW AND WOOD
CHIPS AND OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL WEEKS COULD DEFINITELY
BROKEN DOWN INTO THE SOIL.
MICROBIAL ACTIVITY. OVER THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS TOGETHER WITH
RESEARCHERS FROM SEVERAL MAJOR
UNIVERSITIES WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT THE SAME PROCESS NOW
CALLED NATURAL ORGANIC
PRODUCTION. AND EFFECTIVE FOR
HUMAN DISPOSITION. IN ADDITION
TO BEING A NATURAL ORGANIC
PRODUCTION IS SUSTAINABLE AND
GENTLE ON THE PLANET. IT
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS IN
CARBON EMISSIONS OVER
CONVENTIONAL BURIAL OPTIONS YOU
CAN GET THEM IN THE ENERGY
EXCLAMATION I THINK OVER METRIC
TON OF CARBON DIOXIDE PER
PERSON TO CHOOSE. WASHINGTON
STATE LEGALIZED NATURAL ORGANIC
PRODUCTION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WHICH ALLOWED
RECOMPOSED CIRCLE CAN OUR DOORS
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. THE
FILM TURNED OVER FORTY FIVE
HUMANS INTO SOIL. IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR TO WORK WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE SAME
LEVEL AND MEANINGFUL SEARCH
WHAT. FINANCIAL TIMES OPERATING
GROUP ALSO GENERATED FOURTEEN
JOBS. IT'S REALLY EXCITING FOR
ME TO BE AN ENTIRELY NEW CLEAR
PATH COMBINING ECOLOGY
HOSPITALITY AND END OF LIFE
CARE COME TO LIGHT. FINALLY
OVER TWO HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WROTE IN A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL AND
COLLABORATING WITH FILM
DIRECTORS FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE IT'S BECOME CLEAR THAT
CALIFORNIANS WANT MORE CHOICE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE END OF
LIFE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND SUPPORT. SAYING NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WAYS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
ZERO ONE. THING NONE. LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE ZERO ONE WILL BEGIN. IF
YOU'RE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE ZERO ONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE A LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THE LINE NUMBER. AND WE
WILL MOVE TO LINE FORTY ONE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THIS IS ALEXA
TRAVIS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE OH ONE
THANK YOU. TEXT MR HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE WOULD YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. LET'S NOW
ADDRESS WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE A
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE ZERO ONE.
SEEING NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR HE WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
THIS MEASURE A. B. FIVE ZERO
ONE WILL BEGIN. AND IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
FIVE ZERO ONE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
STRUCTURE WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE CHAMBER.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS R CONCERNS CINNAMON
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN LET'S. THAT'S
NOTED ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS- SENATOR
JOE BLOW DID YOUR MAKEUP OKAY
CENTER PANEL FOR SERVICE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE SUMMER
ACTUALLY GO SEE- FOR BRAINS
BILL FORD AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THIS IS BEING
ANOTHER OPTION FOR- FOR A
FUNERAL- JESUS PERHAPS JUST
TOUCH ON I THINK SOME CONCERN
OF IN RACE IN TERMS OF. WHAT
THE GUIDELINES FOR ACTUALLY
THE- THE SOIL GETS CREATED- AND
IT'S- DISPOSITION. ARE IS THERE
ANY GUIDELINES THAT- THAT ARE
IN PLACE FOR THAT- AND REALIZE
SOME OF THEM MAY HAVE TO DO AS
MUCH WITH PEOPLES- PERHAPS-
SUPERSTITIONS ARE I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S A DIFFERENT WAY TO PUT
IT BUT YOU KNOW. ABOUT TOOK
PLACE IN HUMAN REMAINS- AS MUCH
AS ANYTHING ELSE BUT- PERHAPS
YOU CAN SPEAK TO. THE
GUIDELINES FOR DISPOSAL OF
BASICALLY THE WHAT. WHAT DO YOU
DO WITH THEM SO IT'S CREATED.
THANK YOU SO WE DID TAKE THEM
IN TO GIVE THE BUREAU AN EXTRA
YEAR TO IMPLEMENT THIS TO HELP
DEVELOP WHAT THOSE GUIDELINES
WOULD BE. MUCH LIKE WE'VE
DEVELOPED GUIDELINES FOR WHEN
WE ARE GOING TO. BE CREMATED
BODY WHAT WE DO LITTLE FASCIST-
AS WELL AND SO IT'S JUST
ANOTHER OPTION I THINK FOR
FOLKS WHO DO HAVE. MAYBE THIS
MAY NOT ALIGN WITH THEIR VALUES
ARE STILL FOR IT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO USE THIS OPTION TO HAVE
OTHER OPTIONS THAT MIGHT STILL
FIT WITHIN THE VALLEY CENTER.
SO I'M NOT. WANTING TO TAKE
AWAY AN OPTION IT'S AN OPTION
THAT I HAD ACTUALLY HAD A-
LIVELY DISCUSSION WITH MY
PARENTS OR THIS BILL THIS
WEEKEND. MY MOM WAS EXCITED
ABOUT THE IDEA AND MY DAD JUST
COULDN'T. DEAL WITH IT- AND SO
YOU KNOW IT HAS BROUGHT UP A
LOT OF. A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS OF
DEBATING CREATING ONE MORE
OPTION IT IS ALSO A LITTLE.
ENVIRONMENTALLY MORE FRIENDLY
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO CONSIDER.
OUT THERE- AND SO WE NEED THIS
BILLS ALSO THEY'LL REFER TO
HEALTH I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THERE AS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO FIGURE OUT.
SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS US TO
KEEP INDIVIDUALS SAFE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE WHILE ALSO-
BEING RESPECTFUL AND CREATING
IN THE OPTIONS. SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER I THINK IT SAYS
MUCH. NOT JUST THE PERSON ARE
THE FAMILY. THAT MADE DECISION
TO CHOOSE THIS OPTION- MAY BE
OTHER P. WHO HAVE. AND AGAIN
YOU KNOW WE THAT PEOPLE'S.
ASHES OVER YOU KNOW FLORISTS
AND- RIVERS AND- OCEANS AND SO
FORTH- BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE I THINK SOME PEOPLE
MAY EXPRESS SOME DISCOMFORT NOT
KNOWING THAT THEY MAY BE IN. A
PLACE WHERE- SOMEONE'S REMAINS
WERE AT SO IN TERMS OF THE
DISPOSITION AGAIN SELF.
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR VANS-
CINNAMON AT THE SAME ISSUE SO-
CENTER PARENTS KNOW GOT ME
CURIOUS SO I SIMPLY WONDER
SHOULD I DO HAVE A QUESTION
THAT THERE ARE. THE PARTS OF
OUR BODIES THAT DON'T NATURALLY
DECOMPOSE- TEETH FILLINGS
ASSUMED BONES. THAT SO HOW. HOW
DOES IT ALL WORKS OR
MECHANICALLY- SYSTEM OBVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW THE MOST ABOUT IT
TURNS TO SO QUICKLY BUT WHAT
WHAT ABOUT THOSE PARTS THAT
DON'T WORK HOW DO WE DISPOSE OF
THOSE THINGS. AS PART OF THIS
PROCESS THANK YOU AND IN FAITH-
THE TRAVEL OUT IF I COULD HAVE
ONE OF THE WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. ANSWER THAT QUESTION I
THINK THE FIFTH PERSON. YEAH
THE FIFTH BETWEEN PAID FOR
TALKING ABOUT NON ORGANIC
MATERIAL THAT- THAT AREN'T
BROKEN DOWN DURING NATURAL
ORGANIC. PRODUCTION IS THAT
TRUE. THAT'S THE QUESTION BACK
I THINK IT'S BOTH MINUTES IT'S
NOT GOING TO MATERIALS AND IT'S
THOSE PARTS OF THE BODY THAT
DON'T NATURALLY DECOMPOSE AT
THE SAME RATE. AS OTHER PARTS
OF. YES DURING NATURAL ORGANIC
PRODUCTION ALL ORGANIC
MATERIALS INCLUDING BONES AND
TEETH ARE BROKEN DOWN. AND
THAT'S A FACTOR OF. HI HI SPEED
THAT CREATED DURING THE
MICROBIAL ACTIVITY- AND TO
REPLICATE THAT OPERATORS USE TO
ENSURE THE PERFECT ENVIRONMENT
TO- ENTERED MY CREDIT. FOR NON
ORGANIC SUCH AS ATTACKING IN
HIM OR- DENTAL WORK. JUST LIKE
IN CREMATION THERE'S A
SCREENING AND SORTING PROCESS
THAT HAPPENS. AND BELIEVE THOSE
MATERIALS ARE RECYCLED- THERE
ARE COMPANIES OUT THERE THAT
WORK WITH CREMATORY TODAY. THAT
RECYCLED METALS. FROM THE BODY
AFTER CREMATION. THANK YOU MR.
THANK YOU SIR CEREBRAL. YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIR- AND TAKE IT
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW THERE ARE THOSE
IN MY FAMILY WHO ARE ALSO VERY
EAGER TO USE THIS AND I SO I
GUESS IT'S JUST INTERESTING AS
AS WE ARE ALSO TALKING A LOT
ABOUT- THAT. THE WASTE AND AS
WE THINK ABOUT OUR BODIES AND
AT THE END OF OUR LIFE AND
MIGHT COME SO ANYWAY THIS IS
JUST A I THINK ANOTHER STEP IN
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- WORK
AROUND- ED REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF A OF UNNECESSARY WASTE IN
CLOSING THE CYCLE- AND THIS IS
JUST ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF THAT
THAT I THINK IT'S FASTING AND
OF COURSE LIKE MANY THINGS IT
MAKES PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE WE
START TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
ABOUT OF COURSE THIS IS THE
MOST NATURAL WAY I THINK EVER
OF BEING ABLE TO DISPOSE OF A
BODY IN THE- THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY I MEAN THIS IS ABOUT
AS ABOUT OPTIONS IS ABOUT
CHOICES ABOUT. AND ALSO THE
COST FACTOR I MEAN THERE IS A-
D. AT. THE DEATH. AT THE END OF
OUR LIFE- BEARING SOMEBODY
BURIED ANYBODY LIKES IT IS AND
IT CAN BE INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE-
ON FAMILIES. AT THE END OF THE
LIFE AND PUTTING A LOT MORE
THINGS. INTO OUR GROUND SO
ANYWAY IS AS WE TALK ABOUT. BE
ONE MORE WAY OF BEING ABLE TO.
HAVE THE SAY IN OUR LIFE ALL
THE WAY TO THE END I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE. AS WELL AS
BEING ABLE TO. SAVE OUR EARTH
AND DO THINGS IN A VERY NATURAL
WAY. I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR IF I'M NOT ALREADY.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR NEWMAN SOME
WOMEN MEMBER. SKEWS ME CENTER
PANTOMIME AND THEN WE CAN SEE
YOU. BETTER MEN. YEAH- SAID IT
APPRECIATE THE BILL SOME MEMBER
GARCIA I HAD A QUESTION JUST-
I'M READING THE DESCRIPTION OF
THE BILL. AND IT DESCRIBES- ON
OUR ON OUR- PAGE FOR THAT- THE
LIFE THE LICENSEES LIMITED TO
FINAL DISPOSITION- REDUCE HUMAN
REMAINS WITH A LICENSE CEMETERY
BY BERLIN TO MEN FOR
INTERNMENT- FOR CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH HER OWNERSHIP
OF A CONSERVATION AREA WHERE
THE REDUCTION FACILITY MAY
LAWFULLY INTEGRATE THE REDUCED
REMAINS INTO THE SOIL. IS THAT
DOES THAT DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
WE DO WITH- CREMATION.
PERMISSION AND ASK A QUESTION
OF THE SEVEN MEMBER. YEAH I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE THAT IN
FRONT OF ME- I GUESS MAYBE JUST
TO BOIL IT DOWN A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER- YOU KNOW IS IT THE
SAME AS WHAT WE DO IS CREMATED
ASHES OR ARE WE LOOKING AT SOME
DIFFERENT SET OF CRITERIA AND
GUIDANCE. ACCEPTED AT THIS IN
MY VISION IT WOULD BE SIMILAR
RETURN RETURN THESE- THE SOIL
BACK TO THE FAMILY AND THEY GET
TO. PUT IT IN RECENT RIGHT
THERE STILL RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT YOU NEED TO
FALL EVEN FALL EVEN WITH YOUR
AND YOUR FAMILY'S ASHES. I
THINK THE SAME THING WITH THE
WITH THE SOIL TO THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD CREATE GUIDELINES OF WHAT
THAT HI HE SAID AND MAYBE TO- I
APOLOGIZE WHAT WE NEED TO
DISCLOSE HIS WEALTH WITH IT'S
HAPPENING HOW YOU REGISTER
THAT. SO THIS IS ALL PART OF
WHAT THE BUREAU WOULD HAVE TO
DEVELOP- BUT I THINK IT'S
CREATING AN OPTION I THINK
CREATING A CONVERSATION BETWEEN
FAMILY MEMBERS OF WHAT WE DO AT
THE END OF OUR LIFE AND IT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT OFTEN TEND TO
OUR FATE. TO HAVE- I'M THE
CARETAKER FOR MY PARENTS AND
FROM MY UNCLE INTO THE
CONVERSATION I'VE BEEN
CONFRONTED WITH- FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS SINCE I'VE HAD TO
DEAL WITH A WHOLE HOST OF THE
HEALTH CRISIS OUT WITH THEM AND
SO. YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO CREATE A SPACE
WHERE WE KEEP COMMUNITIES
HELPING SAVE CREATURES OF
FAMILIES BUT WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND OUR EXPERTS OF
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD BE
BEST YEAH AND THEN IT'S JUST A
QUICK FOLLOW UP ON THAT- I
DIDN'T SEE THIS AND MAYBE I
JUST MISSED IT I APOLOGIZE IF
SO- IS THERE. GUIDANCE THAT
YOU'RE PROVIDING TO THE BUREAU
OTHER THAN JUST A SORT OF ADOPT
THE SAME GUIDELINES EXCLAMATION
I ONLY ASK THAT BECAUSE- I
THINK THERE ARE PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT IN MY COMMUNITY. AND
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
RELIGIONS DIFFERENT CULTURES
WITH DIFFERENT ATTITUDES ON ON
DEATH AND REMAINS THAT MIGHT
VIEW THESE TYPES OF REMAINS IS
DIFFERENT THAN ASHES AND TO
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO'S POINT. THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE LEGITIMATE RELIGIOUS
OR CULTURAL OR SPIRITUAL
CONCERNS ABOUT HAVING THESE
TYPES. REMAINS LIKE RIGHT NEAR
THEM AND I GUESS- I'M I'M KERRY
IF THERE A- GUIDANCE THAT GOES
ABOVE AND BEYOND JUST. THE IT
POLICY. WORKING IN. TO BE TODAY
THEIR- AND POLICIES. I LOVE
THAT MADE SENSE AND I TALKED.
EARLY ON A MONDAY NO I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND I THINK THE
DISCUSSION ALSO ON WHAT PEOPLE
ARE COMFORTABLE WITH THE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT WHAT WE
DISCLOSED TO THE PUBLIC AND NOT
AND I THINK THAT THERE SHOULD
BE A LEVEL OF THIS CLOSER THAT
IS. OUT THERE- AND THAT IS A
FAIR DISCUSSION TO BE HAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH I WOULD BE
WORKING WITH THE BUREAU ON WHAT
THESE WHAT THE REGULATIONS ARE
LOOK LIKE THEY USED TO HAVE AN
OPEN PROCESS I THINK IT GIVES
PEOPLE SPACE TO PARTICIPATE. IN
THAT AS WELL. ALONG THE WAY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RELIGION-
YOU KNOW THE CATHOLIC CHURCH TO
SOMEONE IS TO BE CREMATED
EITHER- AND SO. IT'S AND PEOPLE
STILL MAKE THAT CHOICE EVEN
WITHIN THAT RELIGION BECAUSE IT
MIGHT BE WORTH IT FOR THEM AND-
THEIR FAMILIES AND WHAT THEY DO
WITH THE FASCIST. THAT THE
DISCUSSION. OFTEN TIME WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS OUT THERE WHAT
HAPPENS. NEXT AND SO I THINK
IT'S FAIR THAT. WE KNOW WHAT'S
IN OUR BACKYARD LITERALLY. NINE
FIFTEEN THAT DISCLOSURES FOR I
WILL SAY FOR EXAMPLE TO THIS
BILL LET DISCOVERED. THAT WERE
ALLOWED TO BURY IT TO FIVE
PEOPLE IN A BACKYARD IN THIS
YOUR CITY OR COUNTY HAS PASSED
AN ORDINANCE THAT. MODIFIES
THAT HE DO THE RIGHT TO SAY
THAT AND PEOPLE MIGHT NOT KNOW
THAT THIS IS NEXT TO YOU IN
YOUR PRIVATE PROPERTY OUT
THERE. AND SO I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF SPACES WHERE WE EXPECTED
AND THINGS AND THERE'S ACTUALLY.
A LOT MORE LATITUDE THAN WE
WOULD REALIZE. I APPRECIATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
HELLO OKAY SIR ARCHULETA- YES-
QUESTION PROBABLY FOR THE
DIRECTOR THE FUNERAL HOME MORE
THAN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER- ACT
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF SHE
WOULD HAVE KNOWLEDGE IN THIS
THE PROCEDURE- WE TALKED ABOUT
THE FAMILIES AND- THE
SENSITIVITY THE FAMILIES WOULD
WOULD THERE BE A NORMAL-
VANTAGE AS WE ALL ARE CUT FROM
THE SCENE AND THEN THIRTY DAYS
LATER WHEN IT'S COMPLETE IS
THERE ANOTHER CEREMONY- CAN YOU
WALK ME THROUGH WHAT WOULD BE.
A SORT OF A CEREMONY I MEAN IT-
USUALLY THERE'S GRAVESITE AND
THEN THE CASKET IS- IS PUT IN
THE GROUND OR THERE'S- YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT WHAT EXACTLY WHAT
WOULD TAKE PLACE WHEN WITH THE
FAMILIES ACTUALLY MOURN WOULD
IT BE AT THE END OF THIRTY DAYS
IN THE BEGINNING. WHAT'S THE
PROCEDURE I GUESS WHAT SO LET'S
HAVE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERIC
THAT AND THEN RE DIRECT THAT IF
YOU WOULD. I DON'T KNOW WHO'S
ON THE LINE AT ALL ALL. AT ONE
THIRTY THAT FUNERAL DIRECTOR SO
I CAN I CAN STEP IN WHATEVER'S
APPROPRIATE. YES AND I WOULD
SAY WHEN WE MOURN OUR FAMILY
MEMBER AUSTIN TEXAS UP TO THAT.
FOR FAMILY MEMBERS AND THAT'S A
DISCUSSION THAT HAPPENS OFTEN
TIMES WITH CREMATION DO WE DO
IT AHEAD OF TIME AFTERWARDS WE
DO WE DO IT TWICE. I'VE I'VE
I'VE HAD. I PARTICIPATED IN
VARIATIONS OF THAT AS WELL BUT
I WILL ALLOW THE DIRECTOR TO
CHAIRMAN. AND DIRECTOR. YEAH
THAT'S A FANTASTIC QUESTION AND
THIS IS A REALLY FASCINATING
TIME TO BE A PART OF THE
FUNERAL INDUSTRY. BECAUSE
THINGS ARE CHANGING AND THERE
ARE NEW IDEAS AND WE HAVE
DIFFERENT RELIGIONS AND
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING IT. BUT
AS I WILL SAY I DO MOSTLY
CREMATION. OR NATURAL BURIALS
WHICH IS JUST A BOTTOM STRAIGHT
INTO THE GROUND- AND- NORMALLY
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT YOU TEND
TO HAVE A VIEWING AFTER THE
TONE BECAUSE PEOPLE DO YOU WANT
TO BE WITH THE PHYSICAL BODY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
LOVE SO MUCH ABOUT THE IDEA OF
NATURAL ORGANIC REDUCTION IS
THAT POLICING THE BODY INTO THE
VESSEL. TO BE TO BE REDUCED TO
SOIL. IS SUCH A- BEAUTIFUL
CALMING WAY BECAUSE CREMATORY
LET'S BE HONEST TEND TO BE VERY
LOUD TEND TO BE VERY INDUSTRIAL
SO WHEN WE HAVE FAMILIES COME
TO WITNESS THE BODY BEING
PLACED INTO THE CREMATION
CHAMBER. SOMETIMES I CAN BE A
PRETTY INTENSE EXPERIENCE. BUT
IT'S SO MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN A TRADITIONAL BURIAL AND
GRAVESIDE SERVICE THAT A LOT OF
FAMILIES YOU KNOW HOW TO CHOOSE
CREMATION BUT IN THIS CASE.
BEING ABLE TO CHOOSE NATURAL
ORGANIC PRODUCTION MEANS THEY
HAVE A MUCH. NICER ABILITY TO
HAVE A CEREMONY PRIOR TO THE
BODY BEING INSERTED INTO THE
VESSEL AND THEN AFTER THE
THIRTY DAYS ONCE THE SOIL COMES
BACK. YOU CAN HAVE A MEMORIAL
SERVICE SIMILAR TO WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER CREMATION FOR
THE ASHES ARE SCATTERED. AND A
QUICK- RETURNS WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER WITH THE
DISCUSSION I BELIEVE THAT IT
WILL BE VERY SIMILAR TO HOW
CREMATED REMAINS ARE HANDLED
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY HAS SOME OF
THE MOST STRICT LAWS AROUND
HANDLING THE CREMATED REMAINS.
PRIOR OR AFTER THE CREMATION
TAKES PLACE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE SO I IMAGINE THE SAME
SORT OF STRICT LAWS AND PERMITS
AND PROCEDURES WILL ALSO BE
CARRIED OVER INTO. THE HANDLING
OF THESE ORGANIC REMAINS. THANK
YOU MUCH FOR. THANK YOU SIR
OKAY COLLEAGUES FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
LAST CALL. SEEING NONE. THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN SEMI MEMBER GARCIA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WHEN I THINK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAVING AROUND THIS ISSUE TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I HOPE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
ZERO ONE D. PASSES AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMENDMENT REFERS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH ROTH NINE
ROTH HI MELINDA'S ARCHULETA.
ARCH A LOT I'D BEAT UP LOADING.
BACKER HI BACKER HI TODD. EIGHT
MEN RIGHT HEY MAN HI HER TADO
HI HER TADO I'D JONES LEYVA MAN.
NEWMAN HI NIMIN I'D SHOW A
BOGEY ON A SHOW ABOUT IPN HI HE
N. I. WAS ABLE TO HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR- ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU AS A MEMBER. LET'S NOW MOVE
TO- ITEM NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORREO. AND THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. FOUR SIX TWO.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBER CENTER OFF I
BELIEVE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT I PRESENT IN YOUR
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL AND ALSO TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME THE NEW
MEMBERS AND RETURNING MEMBERS
TO THE SENATE WHO ARE HEARING
FROM MY COLLEAGUES AND I IN THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE FIRST TIME I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIX TWO WHICH REMOVES THE
UNNECESSARY REQUIREMENT A
CALIFORNIA LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS KNOWN AS EL PCC'S.
COMPLETE ADDITIONAL COURSEWORK
AND TRAINING HOURS TO WORK WITH
COUPLES AND FAMILIES WORK THAT
THEY ARE ALREADY DOING AND I
WILL PREPARE FOR AFTER
COMPLETING ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THEIR LICENSE AB FOUR SIX
TWO ALSO CLEARS BARRIERS IN THE
WORKFORCE PIPELINE BY REMOVING
THE REQUIREMENT THAT ASSOCIATE
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS COMPLETE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY HOURS OF TRAINING IN A
HOSPITAL OR COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH CLINIC SETTING AS PART
OF THEIR TRAINING TO BEAT TO
BECOME AN LPC SEE. BOTH OF
THESE REQUIREMENTS ONLY
EXISTING CALIFORNIA AND
CONSEQUENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SECOND LOWEST EMPLOYMENT RATE
OF MENTAL HEALTH WORKERS IN THE
UNITED STATES AS ASSOCIATES
PROSPECTIVE L. PCC'S MUST
ALREADY COMPLETE THREE THOUSAND
SUPERVISE TRAINING HOURS OF
WHICH SEVEN ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ARE IN DIRECT
CLINICAL COUNSELING WITH
INDIVIDUALS GROUPS COUPLES OR
FAMILIES L. PTC'S LEARN HOW TO
WORK WITH INDIVIDUALS OF ALL
AGES RACES SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS SEXUAL
ORIENTATIONS. GENDER IDENTITIES
AND ABILITIES AND THEY LEARN
HOW TO RESPOND TO INDIVIDUALS
IN CRISIS AMONG ALL OF THESE
EXISTING EDUCATIONAL CLINICAL
REQUIREMENTS L. P. THESES ARE
TRAINED EXTENSIVELY TO
UNDERSTAND FAMILY AND
RELATIONSHIP DYNAMICS AND TO
UNDERSTAND THEM THROUGH A MULTI
CULTURAL LENS TO UNDERSTAND OUR
ETHICAL OBLIGATIONS TO
INTERVENE AND PREVENT HARM TO
CHILDREN AND TO UNDERSTAND SOME
SYSTE PUES PARTNER VIOLENCE
AGING AND HOW MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AFFECT THE ENTIRE
FAMILY CALIFORNIA LICENSE
PROFESSIONAL CLINIC COUNSELORS
RECEIVE EDUCATION AND TRAIN.
THAT IS EXTEND. AND WELL
ROUNDED PREPARING THEM TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE. EQUITY IN ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES A
LONGSTANDING ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA AND HAS ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED BECAUSE OF COPING
NINETEEN. THIS BILL WILL HELP
US MAKE MORE LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS AVAILABLE. TO THE
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED IT THE
MOST TO TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE.
IS JB AIRS AND KENNETH EDWARDS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELORS. THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED WITH THIS IS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS G. B.
AIRS I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELOR
OR THE SPONSOR THE BABY FOR
SIXTY TWO. I APPRECIATE YOU-
CHAIR MEMBERS- WE'RE
CONSIDERING THIS BILL AND ALSO
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
SEVEN MEMBER CREO FOR OFFERING
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION WHICH
IS VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
IN CALIFORNIA BECAME. THE
FIFTIETH STATE AND FINAL STATE
A LICENSED. PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELORS IN AT TWO
THOUSAND NINE. THAT LATE IN THE
PROCESS TWO AMENDMENTS WERE
ADDED TO THE BILL WHICH- WHICH
THIS BILL IS A DRESS TODAY-
SOME- SOME ELEVEN YEARS OR
TWELVE YEARS SINCE THAT. TIME
HAS- THAT BILL WAS ENACTED- AND
LOOKING AT HOW THINGS HAVE
PROGRESS IT'S TIME TO- WE
BELIEVE IT'S TIME TO REMOVE
THOSE BARRIERS TO. LICENSURE
AND EMBARRASSED PRACTICE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA NO OTHER STATE IN
THE NATION PROHIBITS LICENSED
COUNSELORS. AFTER WORKING WITH
COUPLES AND FAMILIES NO OTHER
STATE REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION AND TRAINING IN ORDER
TO ASSESS AND TREAT COUPLES AND
FAMILIES. ONLY CALIFORNIA QUITE.
I MISSILE LICENSED CARE. AND-
AND- THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT
SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS FOR SOCIUS
TO COMPLETE A HUNDRED FIFTY
HOURS IN A COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH OR HOSPITAL SETTING IS
OUTSIDE THE STANDARD PRACTICE
FOR POSTGRADUATE OUR
REQUIREMENTS- FOR THIS- FOR
THIS LICENSE NATIONALLY SIMPLY
PUT NO OTHER STATE MAKES
REQUIREMENTS FOR- THIS LICENSE
YOUR CHOCOLATE BELIEVES THAT
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARD EQUITY AND ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE ON THIS I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE CELTICS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR KENNETH. EDWARDS TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL. PLEASE
PROCEED WE WERE GOOD MORNING
PLEASE BE AWARE OF OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS. PLEASE PROCEED.
GREAT GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KENNETH EDWARD TECHNIQUES
ACTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR LPC
FEES THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE AND THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO AS WE
KNOW LPC FEES HAVE BEEN IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ABOUT TEN YEARS
NOW AND WE'VE SHOWN OURSELVES
CAPABLE CONDITION. OF OBTAINING
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT FROM OUR PEERS WE WANT
TO SEE MORE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO UPHOLD THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS OF PRACTICE AND
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP THE
WORKFORCE ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS LAST YEAR CALLED IN WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ACCESS TO CARE AND THIS BILL
WOULD HELP INCREASE THAT FOR
EVERY STATE A RESIDENT HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
FROM OUR MEMBERS EVERY DAY AT
FOLLOWED BY COMMISSIONS THAT
THEY'RE UNABLE TO WORK ACROSS
THE STATE BECAUSE OF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS OR IT MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT TO COMPLETE-
LIKE NOTHING COMPARED TO THEIR
PEERS WE ARE CURRENTLY GRATEFUL
ANALYTICS BEFORE FOUNDING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DEAN QUARTER
WHEN I THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN
A LONG BATTLE BUT OUR PATIENT
CLIENT VIRGINITY HAVE BENEFITED
FROM OUR DEATH THREATS AND
RANGE OF EXPERIENCE AND WE
CONTINUE TO APPRECIATE YOUR.
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. NO- FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GAY. WHO HERE AND- SAYING
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITH IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIX TWO. SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES READY TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
URBIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUAL'S
WAITING TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIX TWO
WE'LL BEGIN. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIX TO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN ONE MOMENT
LEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THE
LINE NUMBERS TO THOSE QUEUED UP.
GOOGLE FIRST LINE FORTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS
ROSEANNE HOME ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
AND THE BOARD IS IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS WE HAVE NO
FURTHER- THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MISS PERU- LET'S NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR WITNESSES IN. OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE LET'S CHECK
TO SEE IF THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIX TWO
FINOS SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR WAS
MISSED BY WRITER IF YOU PLEASE
PROPPED ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WILL BEGIN. IF YOU
WERE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS MEASURE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ONE
LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE THE
PROVIDER LINE NUMBER. THE
BOTTOM LINE FORTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS DR
ANTI RELIGIOUS I AM A COUNSELOR
EDUCATOR AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- DUE TO THE ONEROUS
REQUIREMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE YOU PPC THEY
CREATE A DIVERSE- QUALIFIED
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS WHO SERVE
OUR CONSTITUENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- INTERNSHIP HOURS OKAY
CRAP PROGRAM ON WHICH I TEACH
AND- FAR BUT WRITTEN BY LAW
ACTUALLY INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
THAT- SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
PERFORM. OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
HOURS CLINICALLY- SO THAT
HUNDRED FIFTY HOURS WITH THE
POP AND BEYOND SEVEN HUNDRED-
OUR- INTERNSHIP ALMOST
SOMETIMES UP TO A THOUSAND
HOURS OF INTERNSHIP- AND SO. ON
AND SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SIR. MODERATELY OR THERE
ANY OTHER WITH IN ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. AT THIS POINT WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE TO. THANK YOU SIR
LET'S BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE-
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE SO REMEMBER CAREER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. DID I
MISS ONE. SENATOR REAGAN I
MISTER MIKE I APOLOGIZE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MR CHAIRMAN I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD ALTHOUGH.
AS HAVING ONE OF THE OTHER
LICENSEES WERE LIBERTAIRE TOTAL
ABOUT IT BUT- SINCE YOU'VE BEEN
HERE AROUND TEN YEARS NOW YOU
MIGHT AS WELL GET YOU'VE I
WOULD GIVE IT A GOOD TRIAL SO
WE MIGHT AS WELL EXPANDABLE BIT
MORE SO. WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL WE CERTAINLY.
HAVE A DEARTH OF A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND WE
HEAR THAT EVERY DAY THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH FOR. PEOPLE TO- TO BE
ABLE TO HIRE ENOUGH AND AS
WE'RE GETTING READY HOPEFULLY
TO MAKE A HISTORIC INVESTMENT
IN OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND
EXPAND OUR ACCESS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ALSO EXPAND THE
WORKFORCE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. AND WITH THAT I'D I'D
MOVE THE BILL THANK OU THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
EDMUND ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAREER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I-
SERVER- AS THE ASSEMBLY
APPOINTEE TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS NOW
ENTERING MY FOURTH YEAR IN
OFFICE AND EVERY YEAR WE HEAR
EXACTLY- WHAT SENATOR EDMUND
JUST MENTIONED A SEVERE LACK OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO
ACTUALLY ASSIST OUR COMMUNITIES
AND- AS MORE EXPANSION OF
MENTAL HEALTH CARE- IS. IS
MOVING FORWARD IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT THE WORK FORCE IT'S
ACTUALLY THERE TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES AB FOUR SIX TO REMOVE
UNNECESSARY ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH COUPLES AND FAMILIES. AND
REMOVES WORKFORCE PIPELINE
BARRIERS IN THE PROFESSION
MAKING MORE WELL TRAINED AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AVAILABLE
TO THE CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED
THEM THE MOST. AS YOU HEARD A
BEFORE SIX TO HAVE THE SUPPORT
OF THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SUCH
AS SCIENCES NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT GIVEN THE
INCREDIBLE NEED. TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACROSS OUR STATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM FIVE AS- BILL
FORSTER TWO DO YOU HAVE AND WE
WERE. TO THE- ON APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS IF YOU COULD PLEASE
MAKE SURE TO SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE. RALPH HI. RALPH HI
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA HI-
CHILLOUT IBEATS. BACKER HI.
BACKER I'D DIED. EIGHT MEN. HI
ADNAN I HER TADO. JONES LEYVA.
MAIN MAIN I KNEW MEN I. KNEW
MAN I SHOW A BOGUS HIGH. BUT
SHOW ABOUT A GUY P. N. HI HE N.
I. WHO'S EIGHT VOTES HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSOLUTE THANK
THANK YOU. LET'S NOW TURN TO. I
AM NUMBER ELEVEN SO MY MEMBER
GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FOUR FOUR YOU'VE BEEN SITTING
AWHILE.
GENTLEMEN IT MATTERS
NOT TO ME YOU'RE BOTH HERE WHO
WANTS TO PROCEED FIRST. BECAUSE.
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER NINE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THREE EIGHT TO SIMPLY MEMBER
RESEARCH G. FACTORY MUST-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU-
TO SOMEONE OVER GRAYSON FOR
GRACIOUSLY. PUTTING BEING. GO
FIRST- SANDERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A. B FIVE THREE EIGHT
OF WHICH IS A PROPOSAL TO
CREATE. CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION. AS MANY OF US KNOW-
CALIFORNIA'S AEROSPACE INDUSTRY
IS A NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADER
IN AEROSPACE INNOVATION. AND
JOB CREATION HOWEVER- THE STATE
HAS SEEN MANY REDUCTIONS IN ITS
WORKFORCE- AND HIS SIZE OVER
THE YEARS ESPECIALLY SINCE THE
NINETIES AFTER. A SIGNIFICANT
DEFENSE CUTBACKS. ABOUT WHY WE
HAVE SEEN NEW OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION OR IN IN THE
INDUSTRY- PARTICULARLY. IN
AREAS OF COMMERCIAL SPACE
FLIGHT UNMANNED. DRONE
MANUFACTURING AND RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT. AND SO THIS
COMMISSION AS A PROPOSAL AS A
FOR A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP TO BRING THE
INDUSTRY LEADERS. TOGETHER WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE- TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADVISE US ON
HOW BEST TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN
A GOOD PAYING AEROSPACE JOBS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES. JUDY KRUEGER
WITH THE LOS ANGELES ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. AND
PROFESSOR ALEX BRYAN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. THANK YOU SIR YOUR
WITNESSES MAY PROCEED. MS
KRUEGER. ALEX BUYING HERE I WAS
ELECTED SECOND SO I WOULD
ASSUME I WOULD GO SECOND. HI
THIS IS JUDY. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING-
COMMITTEE CHAIR ROD AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M HONORED TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT AND I REPRESENT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AN
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
ADVANCING OPPORTUNITY AND
PROSPERITY FOR ALL I AM PLEASED
TO OFFER SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY
BUILT BY THIRTY EIGHT WE
BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT THAT IT BALANCES THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
COMMISSION WILL ENHANCE THE
GLOBAL COMPETITIVENESS. OF THE
STATE'S EARTH DAYTON DEFENSE
INDUSTRY WHICH IS THE HISTORIC
IN A RAPIDLY EVOLVING INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY BOTH A GDP
EXCEEDING THAT AT THE STATE
OWNED TELEVISION AND
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES
COMBINED OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
DIRECTLY EMPLOYED IN THE
INDUSTRY WITH MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYED IN
RELATED FIELD THESE ARE GOOD
PAYING JOB AND THEIR JOB THAT
WILL HELP IN OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND SUSTAINABLE
RECOVERY AND LONG TERM.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPERS WE SEE THIS
AEROSPACE COMMISSION AS A
LEADING AGENCY THAT WORKS WITH
SANE AND SUPPORT AND- AEROSPACE
AND SPACE INDUSTRY GLOBALLY
COMPETITIVE AS A SIDE NOTE I
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE LED
SEAT FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS
BUT PRIOR TO THAT I WORKED FOR
THE STATE OF MICHIGAN AND WE
PAID- TO COME TO CALIFORNIA
RECRUIT AEROSPACE COMPANIES
BACK TO THE STATE OF MICHIGAN.
SO WITH THAT IN MY BACKGROUND I
AM HONORED AND DELIGHTED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THE A
CALIFORNIAN WHO SAYS WE NEED TO
SUPPORT YOUR CHURCH GROW OUR
AEROSPACE SPACE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE THIS IS OUR LEGACY
THESE ARE GOOD PAYING JOB AND I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
US IN- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS LEADERS IN THE
INDUSTRY THAT WILL SPPORT THE
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT THE
GROWTH OF THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
REGULAR AND MEMBERS THE END OF
YOUR AFTER TODAY NAME IS ALEX
BY I WORK FOR YOU TO BERKELEY
THE PROPER ARE BACK TO INJURING
COMPUTER. WHERE I'D THROW THE
DRUG THERE WAS PROBE. HI OVER
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ESTATE
ECONOMIC ACTIVE TO PUT WITH IN
MOTHER FIELD AND- WITH THE-
WHICH UC BERKELEY JUST ENTERED
A LEASE. AGREEMENT TO THE AN
HOUR WHICH PROBE. IF YOU'VE GOT
ACCORDING TO THE THIS. BILL IN
THE THIRTY ARE MY OWN AND NOT
THAT OF THE RISK OF. CALIFORNIA
BUT IF SOMEONE. OF ERROR
COMMISSION INCREASE. CALIFORNIA
GROCERY LEADERSHIP IT WILL.
PROMINENT IN THE U. S. IN THE
WELL. IT WAS UNABLE TO THE TO.
IT GLOBALLY IN INSTRUMENTATION
TECHNOLOGY. BECKER WHO LIVE FOR
THE CHALLENGE OF AUTOMATED
FLIGHT AND THIRD. TO BECOME THE
WORLD LEADER IN COMMUNICATION
OUT THERE BUT ALSO HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET. ITS MOST
AMBITIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
YOU THE BERKELEY AND CONSIDERED.
HOW SEVEN DECADES OF X. TO THE
STATE I'M FROM MY- SEVERAL OF
WHICH CONCERN AND RESPECT AND
IN PARTICULAR. THE UNIVERSITY
OF SUPPORT OF THE STATE ON
TECHNICAL RESEARCH STAFF ON
PROJECT FOR CORBIN CALTRANS FOR
EXAMPLE THE CRITIC THE PORTALS
PROGRAM THE ACCIDENT IN LOS
ANGELES. A SUPPORTS THIS FROM
PUBLIC FROM AND AT THE ONE FROM
PROJECT FOR EXAMPLE. TO HELP
OUT TWINS WITH TWO PRISM AND
OUR TECH TRANSFER PROGRAM AND
WORK FOR STREAMING- LOTS OF
STAFF ON BEHALF OF THE STATE.
AGENCY AN AGENCY. OF ALL THE
REASONS I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THE STATE WITH THIS
NEW COMMISSION AND IN THE LONG
TRADITION OF UC BERKELEY THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SIR NOW
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND SUPPORT I SEE NO
SUCH WITNESSES. FURTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THREE EIGHT.
I SEE NO WITNESSES LET'S TURN
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THREE EIGHT
WILL BEGIN. IF YOU'RE SPEAK IN
SOME OF SOME BILL FIVE THREE
EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX GO
AHEAD. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SOVIET POLICE SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AT CURRENT COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. BUT THE FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TURNING TO
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE A
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THREE
EIGHT. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THREE EIGHT
WILL PROCEED. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THE STRUCTURE WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME FINE LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION NOW BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SEEING
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID SHE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE REMOTE
SHIP THIS MEASURE RECEIVED A
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH
NO NO VOTES IN THE SIMPLY HAS
NO LISTED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
MAY I HAVE A MOTION PLEASE.
SEARCH A LOT OF MOVES THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NINE A. B. FIVE
THREE EIGHT KEEP PASSING RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROTH IRA
MELENDEZ ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
I'D BE BECKER. BECKER I DIED
EIGHT MEN EIGHT MEN I HER TADO
JONES LEAVE A MAN I MEAN I KNEW
MAN BY WOMEN I SHOW A BOGUS HI
AND SHOW A BUG HAND BY HAND I
WAS ABLE TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SIR. SOMEONE MEMBER GRAYSON
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. GOOD MORNING SURE
RAFA AND SENATORS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY FOUR THE BAY AREA IS THE
SECOND LARGEST OIL REFINING
CENTER ON THE WEST COAST
COUNTRY COSTA AND SOLANO
COUNTIES ARE HOME TO FIVE
OPERATIONAL REFINERIES MEMBER
STATE POLICIES INCLUDING A
SERIES OF RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. BY THE GOVERNOR HAVE
SIGNALED CALIFORNIA'S INTENT TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS AND TOWARD MORE
SUSTAINABLE RENEWABLE FORMS OF
ENERGY WELL THIS IS A LAUDABLE
AND IMPORTANT GOAL IT PRESENTS
A UNIQUE SET OF CHALLENGES FOR
THE EAST BAY. WHOSE ECONOMY IS
BOLSTERED BY THOUSANDS OF GOOD
PAYING UNION JOBS IN THE ENERGY
SECTOR AND THOUSANDS MORE IN
ANCILLARY INDUSTRIES STATE
POLICY MAKERS MUST ENSURE THAT
ANY TRANSITION TO GREEN
TECHNOLOGY IS DONE WITH CLARITY
FOR SITE AND A FOCUS ON THE
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF WORKERS
IN AFFECTED INDUSTRIES IN SHORT
WE MUST ENSURE THAT ALONG WITH
THE PROMISE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. WE ACHIEVE ECONOMIC
JUSTICE FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS AB
EIGHT FORTY FOUR WILL AUTHORIZE
THE CREATION OF A GREEN
EMPOWERMENT ZONE FOR THE
NORTHERN WATERFRONT AREA OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THIS ZONE
WILL PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK TO
PROBE PRIORITIZED ACCESS TO TAX
INCENTIVES GRANTS LOAN PROGRAMS
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS IN
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT IN
CLEAN AND GREEN ENERGY SECTOR.
WHEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED THE ZONE
WILL ALLOW STAKEHOLDERS TO
LEVERAGE THE FULL SCOPE OF
AVAILABLE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
TOOLS INCLUDING FEDERAL
EMPOWERMENT ZONES AND
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITIES PROMISE
AND OPPORTUNITY ZONES THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
AND ADVANCED TRANSPORTATION
FINANCING AUTHORITY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION'S
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
AND THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS HI ROAD
TRAINING PROGRAM. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO SERVE AS A BRIDGE TO
FACILITATE THE TRANSFER OF
RESOURCES EXPERTISE. AND
INFORMATION BETWEEN A HELLO
STATE AND FEDERAL. WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENT IN THE GREEN ENERGY
SECTOR COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE STRUCTURES IN PLACE TO
RECEIVE AND MAKE GOOD USE OF
ANY NEW RESOURCES. AVAILABLE TO
US WELL THIS BILL IS LIMITED IN
GEOGRAPHICAL SCOPE TO THE EAST
BAY AREA I HOPE THAT IT CAN
EVENTUALLY SERVE AS A MODEL FOR
OTHER REGIONS TO ORGANIZE AND
BUILD ON THEIR UNIQUE
ADVANTAGES TO SPUR ECONOMIC
GROWTH. I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
TODAY TO TALK ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL AND GIVE BRIEF
TESTIMONY. KRISTEN CONNOLLY
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF EAST BAY
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND CHUCK
LEONARD BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE
WITH YOU A LOCAL THREE FOUR
TWO. WITNESSES MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIR ROB AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS KRISTEN
CONNOLLY AND THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE EAST BAY LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL WHICH IS THE REGIONAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
EMPLOYERS IN CONTRA COSTA AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY. ORGANIZATION
HAD MORE THAN EIGHTY YEARS OF
HISTORY AND SUPPORT OF OUR
MISSION TO IMPROVE ECONOMIC
VITALITY AND QUALITY OF LIFE.
INVASION HAS ALSO SUPPORTED THE
NORTHERN WATERFRONT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVES IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH I THOUGHT
TO PRESERVE INDUSTRIAL LAND. TO
ENCOURAGE THE CREATION OF HIGH
WAGE HIGH SKILL JOBS ALONG THE
NORTHERN WATERFRONT. CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. WE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GREAT COMPLETE
OR SEVEN OFFERING EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY FOUR TO CREATE A CONTRACT
AGREEMENT POWERMAN DOWN AND
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH TO
IMPROVE THE BILL THROUGH
AMENDMENTS TO OUR REGION'S
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR HAS BEEN SO
CRITICAL TO THE FACT THAT BOTH
THE BAY AREA AND THE STATE
ECONOMY BECAUSE RELIABLE ENERGY%
AS A PART OF THE WRITING
ECONOMY THE TRADITIONAL ENERGY%
SECTOR HAS HELPED TO BUILD THE
MIDDLE CLASS IN OUR REGION AND
INTERNATIONALLY REPRESENTED ONE
THIRD OF OUR GROSS REGIONAL
PRODUCT. THE STRENGTH OF THE
FACTOR HAS HELPED CATALYZE
CONFER CONSTANT COMPARATIVE
ADVANTAGE IN BOTH GREEN ENERGY
AND WATER TECHNOLOGY- WHICH IS
WITH IDENTIFIED MORE THAN TEN
YEARS AGO AND THIS BILL WILL
HELP US FURTHER REALIZED THE
POTENTIAL IN THE SECTOR THE
SUCCESS OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WHICH IS A SIMILAR MODEL
AND NOT TODAY ALSO HAS WRITTEN
CONTRACT THAT BECAUSE EVERYBODY
RIGHT NOW LEADERSHIP WHO IS THE
FORMER C. CUT LONGTIME CONTRACT
THAT MEMBER. OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AND THAT. I CAN
REMEMBER GRACENOTE TO THE-
RIGHT. AND AS OUR STATE. BUT
ELECTRICAL THE CASE OF OUR
STATE TWEET AND I IMPORT
MILESTONE. AND THEY STILL WILL
HELP OUR REGION FACES
CHALLENGES. SOME OF THE
GREATEST INNOVATIONS IN
DEVELOPING RENEWABLE FUELS ARE
BEING DRIVEN BY THE FIVE
REFINERIES IN CONTRA COSTA AND
SOLANO COUNTY. SHE REFINERIES
HAD PENDING APPLICATIONS TO
CONVERT EXCLUSIVELY TO PRODUCE
RENEWABLE DIESEL. SENATOR I AM
ASKING FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR BECAUSE
THE ESTABLISHMENT THE CONTRACT
AGREEMENT HARM DONE. CREATE A
FRAMEWORK FOR A NEW LEVEL OF
COLLABORATION AND COOPERATION
BETWEEN ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. WELL ESTABLISHING
AN IMPORTANT ROLE OR KEY
STAKEHOLDERS. STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDE OUR REGION'S NATIONAL
LABORATORY INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND KEEP
PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS. THE
STRUCTURE WILL FACILITATE OUR
REGION'S ABILITY TO RECEIVING
FEDERAL STATE AND OTHER SUPPORT
AVAILABLE TO INVEST. IN OUR
REGION'S WORKFORCE AT LEAST YOU
CAN GROW GREEN TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING RENEWABLE DIESEL AND
CARBON CAPTURE. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN HELPING ENSURE
CHORDS YOU'RE MORE EQUITABLE
INCLUSIVE. AND SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY THANK YOU. THE YOU MS
COLOR. MR GOOD MORNING- TO THE
TO IN THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHUCK LEONARD I'M A BIT THE
THREAT REPRESENTATIVE FOR
PLUMBERS AND STEAM FITTERS
LOCAL THREE FORTY TWO AND I TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF A. B. EIGHT
FORTY FOUR THIS BILL IS GOOD
FOR THE COMMUNITY GIVES THE
OVERSIGHT NECESSARY GET INSURED
THAT THE HIGH LABOR STANDARDS
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WILL
CONTINUE TO STAY STRONG. AND
TRANSPARENT. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THEN- FORESIGHT. COME UP WITH
THIS- COME UP WITH THIS BILL AT
A AT THE LABOR- BUILDING TRADES
IN CONTRAST THE COUNTY LOOKS AT
JUST TRANSITION AND WHAT THAT
PORTFOLIO WORK LOOKS LIKE-
WITH- CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION GREEN GREEN
HYDROGEN- AT THAT LOOK AT
RENEWABLE FUELS AND BIO DIESEL
I THINK THIS BILL IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO CREATE- JUST
TRANSITION. TO THOUSANDS OF
UNION WORKERS IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
LET'S NOW HEAR FROM WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY AND SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE. CHECK WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. SEEING NONE
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FOUR FOUR WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE SHOWED UP AT THIS TIME.
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR MANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
BEGINNING WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. SAYING NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FOUR FOUR
WILL BEGIN. AND IF YOU'RE
WAITING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN RICHARD
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU LET'S RETURN TO THE CHAMBER
AND MY COLLEAGUES AND I SEE
SENATOR PAN HAS A QUESTION FOR
THEM TO MOVE THE BILL. OF THE
BILL. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS COLLEAGUES
SENATOR EDMUND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I LIKE TO THINK THAT THIS
IMMIGRATION FOR THIS I HAVE
SERVED ON THAT IN ADDITION TO
THIS COMMITTEE BOTH UTILITIES
AND NATURAL RESOURCES AND I
KNOW- ABOUT THE- THE CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS THAT KEEP TAKE.
TAKE KEEP TAKING PLACE AS WE
TALKED ABOUT MOVING AWAY FROM A
CARBON BASED ECONOMY AS WE LOOK
AT THAT THAT JUST TRANSITION
FOR OUR WORKERS WE CANNOT
LEAVE- FOLKS BEHIND AND I HAVE
FAMILY BYE BYE FAMILY HELPED
SETTLE AROUND IN AROUND THE
BUSINESS AREA SO I KNOW WHAT
THAT WHAT THAT AREA LOOKS LIKE
WHAT IT SMELLS LIKE. AND THE
RICHNESS OF THAT PLACE IT IN
THE HISTORY OF WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN AND SO I WOULD THIS IS A
BILL I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR FOR AS WELL
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THIS
CONTINUE TO MOVE THROUGH. THIS
HOUSE THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
EDMUND. SEEING NO OTHER MIKES
UP THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN SOME REGRESSION.
FOR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A VOTE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FOUR FOUR DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE ROSS.
ROSS HI MELINDA IS ARCHULETA I.
URGE A LOT I'D BEATS. BACKER BY
BECKER I DIED. EIGHT MEN HI HEY
MAN I HEARD TANTO. JONES LEAVE
THAT. MAN ALL RIGHT MAN I KNEW
MAN HI NEW MAN I A SHOW ABOUT
OKAY I HAVE A SHOW ABOUT A GUY
PNI HE N. I. THEY BOTH WILL
HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR. SIMPLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. BUT ITEM
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE
FIVE SIX TICKET SELLERS. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SIX PROVIDES GREATER
CUSTOMER PROTECTIONS FOR TICKET
BUYERS IT REQUIRES THAT THE
TICKET PRICE FOR A CANCELED
EVENT OF WHICH THERE WERE MANY
DURING HOPE IT BE REFUNDED
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THE
CANCELLATION AND THE TICKET
PRICE FOR POSTPONED OR
SCHEDULED EVENT BE FULLY
REFUNDED WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
A REQUEST BY THE TICKET BUYER.
THE COOK AT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS RESULTED IN A MASSIVE
NUMBER OF UNFORESEEN
CANCELLATIONS OF LIVE EVENTS
WHICH LED FOR A LOT OF PROBLEMS
FOR TICKET BUYERS AND PROTECTED
SELLERS. TICKET SELLERS OFTEN
ATTEMPTED TO OFFER SUBSIDY
PERFORMANCES INSTEAD OF GIVING
PEOPLE THEIR MONEY BACK BUT AND
SOME COMPANIES BECAUSE OF THE
STRAIN OF HAVING TO REFUND A
LOT OF TICKETS QUIETLY AMENDED
THEIR CUSTOMER AGREEMENTS
RETROACTIVELY TO REMOVE THE
REFUND GUARANTEES IN FAVOUR OF
SUBSIDY PERFORMANCES WHETHER OR
NOT THE CONSUMER WANTED TO SEE
THEIR PERFORMANCE. A TICKET
BUYERS WHO ALSO OFTEN FACE A
LOT OF UNINTENDED FINANCIAL
BURDEN BECAUSE OF CODE NINETEEN
PREFERRED MANY TIMES TO RECEIVE
A REFUND RATHER THAN A SUBSIDY
PERFORMANCE BUT DIDN'T HAVE
THAT OPTION. CALIFORNIA CURRENT
LAW STATES THAT A TICKET BUYER
MAY REQUEST A REFUND WHEN AN
EVENT IS CANCELLED. BUT IT
DOESN'T SAY WHEN THEY SHOULD
GET THEIR MONEY BACK AND WE
pWAITING SIX SEVEN EIGHT MONTHS
WHO NEVER RECEIVED A REFUND. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX THAT'S CLEAR
DEADLINE FOR TICKET SELLERS TO
REFUND TICKET BUYERS. IT'S
SUPPORTED BY THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WE WORKED WITH WHATWOULD THE
OPPOSITION WE USED TO HAVE.
TOOK A MOMENT AND WE NOW HAVE
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL WITHOUT EVER.
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS AND I
BOTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LET'S MOVE TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BUILDING WE'LL HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE.
NO SUCH WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH JUST WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX SEEING NONE.
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
RESEARCHER WE HAVE POLICE ONE
PERSON IS SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTIONS FOR THE
BELT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THE TEACHER THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE WOULD SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE AND
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX. WE'LL
PROCEED. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE BRANCH. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. FINE LET'S NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE CHAMBER
AND MY COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR PANNIER FOR OFF OF THE
BILL. OKAY CENTER PANDAS MOVE
THE BILL SENATOR NEWMAN. AT
DATE THANK YOU MR ASSEMBLYWOMAN
FREEMAN I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
YOU. ON THIS BILL THE FOOD HE
LOOKS SURPRISED- THIS IS
PRECISELY THE KIND OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION LEGISLATION THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING- PARTICULARLY
THIS TIME I'D BE GRATEFUL TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF AND
WHEN THAT'S APPROPRIATE- GLAD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR IN THE SENATE BECKER.
YES I SPEAK PREVIOUS APP
AWESOME THANK YOU IN SUPPORT OF
I THINK IN THE IN THE- IN THE-
WITH THE MASSIVE- THE
CONVENIENCE FEES THAT THESE
COMPANIES CHARGE I THINK THEY
CAN FULLY AFFORD TO. BE ABLE TO
DO THESE REFUNDS ARE SUGGESTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
SAYING NO OTHER MIKES UP. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PENICILLIN MEMBER FRIEDMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BE
HAPPY BE HONORED TO ADD YOU AS
A CALL AUTHOR SENATOR NEWMAN
AND- THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN A. B. ONE FIVE FIVE
SIX STEVE HAAS AND RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROSS HI. ROSS
I'M MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I'D BE BACKER BACKER
I'D DIED EIGHT MEN HI HEY MAN I
HEARD HOT IT WAS JONES LEAVE A-
MAN. MAN I KNEW MAN I KNEW MAN
I CHILL ABOUT OKAY HI A
TERRIBLE GUY PNI HE N. I WAS
ABLE TO HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR.
ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT- ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN ZERO SIX SOME REMEMBER
SOMEONE THIS WELCOME THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS AB ELEVEN
OH SIX A BILL I AM JOINTLY
OFFERING WITH MAJORITY LEADER
LEADER RAISE ESTABLISHES A
PILOT PROJECT TO SUPPORT THE
ENHANCEMENT OF A STATE WIDE
TRAINING CENTER NETWORK. WHICH
CAN BE WORKED HAND IN HAND WITH
BUSINESS OWNERS SMALL BUSINESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OTHER
WORKFORCE PARTNERS TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. OVER
TWENTY MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTING CLAIMS HAVE BEEN
FILED IN CALIFORNIA SINCE A
PANDEMIC CAUSED THE CLOSURE OF
BUSINESSES IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY. AS OF APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THEY'RE STILL OVER
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
UNEMPLOYED WORKERS IN THE STATE
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO HAVE NOT MOST
MEN ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN WOMEN AS WE
KNOW AND PEOPLE OF COLOR WITH
LIMITED ACCESS TO EDUCATION AND
TRAINING BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL. A.
B. ELEVEN OH SIX LEVERAGES
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND EXPERTISE
TO RESPOND TO THESE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OF
UNEMPLOYMENT CHALLENGES QUICKLY
AND HELP WORKERS GAIN THE
SKILLS SMALL BUSINESSES NEED IN
ORDER TO SURVIVE DURING THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. I DO HAVE
SEVERAL WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY
INCLUDING CENTER CISCO THE
DIRECTOR AT THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN IN TEXAS AND- I
KP COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS WELL AS
LARRY ABERNATHY A TRAINER WITH
THE RAINING PLACE WITH THE
ECONOMIC WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION. OF BUTTE COLLEGE
THANK YOU- MISS CISCO. MR
ABERNETHY PLEASE PROCEED. YES
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY-
I'M A RETIRED EXECUTIVE- FROM
DAVEY TREE WITH FORTY NINE
YEARS- IN THAT- WITH THAT
COMPANY I SUPPORTED B. ELEVEN
OH SIX THE SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CONTRACT EDUCATION CENTERS. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THERE WAS A
THREE THOUSAND WORKER SHORTAGE
IN- FOR UTILITY LINE CLEARANCE
ARBORS. AND WITH SOME SEED
MONEY FROM P. GINNY I WITNESSED
FIRSTHAND HOW BUCOLIC RAPIDLY
RESPONDED TO THE SHORTAGE OF
TRAINED WORKERS. AND JUST A FEW
MONTHS STAY UP THE DEVELOPMENT
INDUSTRY APPROVED UTILITY LINE
CLEARANCE PROGRAM. IT WAS A TWO
HUNDRED HOURS BYE WEEK COURSE.
THE PROGRAM WAS EXPANDED THE
SEVEN. COLLEGES. WITHIN THE
YEAR EVEN DURING THE- A TENTH.
REGULAR JANE HIGHWAY WILL THE
THIS TRAINING WHEN THEY
GRADUATE THEY CAN GET JOBS-
UNION SCALE STARTING AT TWENTY
ONE DOLLARS AND SIXTY THREE
CENTS AN HOUR AND THEN EXPANDED.
TO THIRTY SIX OH FIVE OVER AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH TRAINING PROGRAM.
JUST BE- MUMBO SIX WILL BRING
MORE AWARENESS TO THE COLLEGE
SUPPORT TO TREAT THE FORGERY
COMPANIES. AND IT WILL PROVIDE.
TRAINING TO MAKE WORKERS
ATTRACTED TO EMPLOYERS. SO I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND THEN WHAT DO YOU LOOK.
THANK YOU SERVICES GO. DO WE
HAVE SANDRA CISCO ONLINE. MY
APOLOGIES I FORGOT TO TAKE MY
TOP OFF A FEW YEARS AFTER
MENTIONED I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU I'M SENATOR
RESIDES IN A THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT FACILITY
LOCATED AT CALIFORNIA STEEL
INDUSTRIES IN FONTANA AND IT IS
THE FIRST PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM EACH
YEAR WE TRAIN AND UPSKILL OVER
A THOUSAND INCUMBENT WORKERS
AND MORE THAN A HUNDRED
UNEMPLOYED UNDEREMPLOYED OR
DISLOCATED WORKERS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE BASICALLY WE PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK IN JAPAN'S
DEMAND INDUSTRIAL TECHNICAL
POSITIONS AND REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP WHICH GARNERED
AWAY DRAIN RANGE OF TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS. TO FORTY TWO DOLLARS
PER HOUR. INTACT AND CON IN
EDUCATION HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS
WE HAVE RECEIVED THE LOCAL
STATE AND NATIONAL RECOGNITION
FOR THE STRIKE WE'VE MADE IN
PARTNERING WITH INDUSTRY. YOUR
PROVIDED QUALIFIED TALENT POOL
OF INDUSTRIAL TECHNICIANS TO
FILL THE HUNDRED INDUSTRIAL
TECHNICAL JOBS THAT GO UNFILLED
EACH YEAR I FOUND ON THIS
BECAUSE IT'S IMPERATIVE TO
UNDERSTAND THE KEY KEY KEY KEY
FUNDING WHEN ONE OF THE
CORNERSTONES FOR BUILDING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH INDUSTRY AND
ULTIMATELY ERECTING THE
REGIONAL TRAINING CENTER.
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO A GROUP OF
MANUFACTURERS CAME TOGETHER
UTILIZING TRAINING FUNDS FROM
ETP. PETERBILT INTENSIVE NOT
QUICK CREDIT TRAINING PROGRAM
TO UPSCALE THEIR WORKFORCE AND
YOU WERE AWARE THIS ISSUE OF AN
UNPREPARED WORKFORCE CONTINUES
TO GROW AND NOW DO TO COPE WITH
THE DEMAND FOR SKILLED WORKERS
HAS ACCELERATED WE HAVE
EMPLOYERS KNOCKING DOWN OUR
DOORS TO RECRUIT STUDENTS AND
WE ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP
WITH THE DEMAND. IN A CUPBOARD
RECOVERING AREA WE NEED TO
INNOVATE NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
MUST PROVIDE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
AND RESOURCES FOR CONTRACT
EDUCATION UNIT THE BETA TEST
COURSES AND PROGRAMS THAT MAY
BE CONSIDERED FOR CREDIT NON
CREDIT AND REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROPERLY. AND
STACKABLE INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED
CERTIFICATES CONTRACT EDUCATION
HAS A LONGSTANDING REPUTATION
AND YOU'RE READY ENGINEERING
AND INNOVATION. CAN RESPOND
RAPIDLY TO INDUSTRY. I CAN YOU
CAN YOU ACROSS THE STATE AND
PART WITH EACH PIECE INTO FOR
TWO. TO DEVELOP A- TO WORK FOR
HI MY IT IS PRETTY TO ANSWER.
FOR THE STATE OF HEALTH EIGHTY
ONE. THANK YOU BYE THE OUT
TRACK RECORD E. G. P. AND THE
NETWORK IN THIRTY TWO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CONTRACT EDUCATION YOU
GET THREE DOT. THREE VERSES ON
THE TIRE WORKERS EACH OF THE
INDUSTRY SECTORS IT WOULD
PROBABLY RECOVERY AREA AND LONG
TERM FUTURE OF WORK THANK. YOU
AND OUR FAMILY. THANK YOU A
CISCO NO TURN TO THE GALLERY TO
CHECK TO SEE IF ARE ANY SO WITH
THERE ARE NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN ZERO SIX I
SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCING
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN ZERO SIX WE WILL BEGIN.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE. THREE ZERO
PRESS ONE AND HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE
THAT HAVE SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK I'M SHOWING THAT
WE HAVE AT LEAST FIVE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU.
AND
WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE. THREE
GOOD MORNING MARTY THEATER FROM
THE RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT HAPPY TO SUPPORT AT
ELEVEN OH SIX AND ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WINE. FIFTY TWO. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ANNA
KREHBIEL REPRESENTED TIMBRE TO
DINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
ON THE COURT AT EIGHTY ELEVEN
OH SIX AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
TWENTY FIVE. WE GOT OUR COLLEGE
OF THE SEQUOIASTRAINING
RESOURCE CENTER DIRECTOR WITH
THE STRONG SUPPORT FOR E. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. LINE FIFTY
SIX. HELLO JOHN MILBURN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
EMPLOYEE TRAINING INSTITUTE AT
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS SANTA
CLARITA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ELEVEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. I
MISS YOU TERRIBLY TO RE
PROMPTING CASE SOMEBODY. FELL
OUT OF Q. ONCE AGAIN TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU HAVE
NOT SPOKEN ALREADY. AND THE
TEACHER KNOW WHEN THE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND- CHECK TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION
AND HEAR FROM THEM LET'S BEGIN
WITH WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
AND SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. TO SEE
IF THERE ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN ZERO
SIX. SINGLE WITNESSES THERE
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AGAIN-
MR MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN ZERO SIX WE WILL PROCEED.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON. ZERO LITERATURE NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE CHAMBERS TO
SEE IF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
I SEE CENTRE ARCHULETA. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF A. B. ELEVEN OH
SIX. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
COMPLIMENT THE AUTHOR AND I'D
BE HONORED TO BE CO AUTHOR. I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
BILL IS SO MEANINGFUL TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I SERVE AND
CERTAINLY THE- COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT ARE IN THE WITHIN
THE THIRTY SECOND SENATE
DISTRICT. BUT I'M SURE CROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING GETTING A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. ESTABLISHING A
PATHWAY TO A BETTER LIFE THE
SKILL SET- TO GET PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THEIR OWN FUTURE
AND IF WE CAN RECOVER FROM THE
ECONOMY. TO GO AHEAD AND BE
PART OF THE ECONOMY THAT'S SO
VERY IMPORTANT IN THESE
EDUCATIONAL STEPS. SECURE IN A
GOOD PAYING JOB THIS IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO AND I'M-
TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU THAT OUR TELECENTRE BECKER.
THE AMERICAN AND THE AUTHOR
JUST MY SEVEN YEARS ON THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE FORD. I
WORKED A LOT AND- HOW WE
INTERACT WITH INDUSTRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE THE JOBS ARE
GOING TO BE AND HOW DO WE
TRAIN. CALIFORNIANS FOR THOSE
JOBS THAT ARE AVAILABLE. AND I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT EFFORT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU
SIR. COLLINGS ANY OTHER DOCTOR
PAN A MOVE TO BUILD. IN HIS
MOVE THE BILL. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SEEING NONE SEVEN MEMBER
SAMANTHA IS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU A CHAIR AGAIN
A. B. ELEVEN OH SIX CONNECTS
TRAINING WITH THE NEEDS OF REAL
BUSINESSES AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I LET HIM
TWELVE EIGHTY ELEVEN- SIXTY
POSSUM REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT ROSS
HI ROSS HI MELINDA'S. ARCH
ALETTA. VIRTUAL LOT I BEAT.
BACKER HI BECKER I DIED. EGGMAN
EGGMAN I. HER TADO HER TADO I'D
JONES HI JONES I. LEIVA MAIN.
BEEN EYEING NEWMAN NEWMAN I I'D
SHOW A BOGUS. A SHOW ABOUT OAK
IPN ALL RIGHT HERE AND I. RIGHT.
YES BILLITON VOTES WILL HOLD
THE MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU. LET'S TURN
BACK TO THE ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
SIMPLY BUILD TWO NINE THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COLOR IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE SENATOR
PAN WILL BE PRESENTING. YES THE.
THANK YOU SHARE A SENATORS-I'M
PRESENTING EIGHTY TO NINETY
THREE ON BEHALF OF THE SUMMER
KALRA WHO UNFORTUNATELY- NOT
ABLE TO MAKE IT THIS MORNING
TO- SO- EIGHTY TO NINETY THREE
IS THE REINTRODUCTION OF
ACTUALLY A SUMMER CALL ROSE EDT
TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO WHICH
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
NO NO VOTES THIS BILL REFLECTS
THE WORK DONE WITH THE CEMETERY
MARJORIE SUSPICION CALIFORNIA
LAST YEAR. WHO ARE NOW NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL EIGHTY TO NINETY
THREE PROVIDES LONG NEEDED
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
UNCLAIMED PRE NEED FUNERAL
ARRANGEMENTS HELD IN TRUST BY
FUNERAL ESTABLISHMENT. USUALLY
THE STATES THAT THE STATE WILL
CONTACT THE FUNERAL
ESTABLISHMENT TO FILL THE
DECEASED'S AGREEMENT FOR
FUNERAL SERVICES. HOWEVER IN
CASES WHERE THE STATE IS NOT
AWARE OF THE TRUST AND DOES NOT
FULFILL THE SERVICES PROMISED
AND PAID FOR THE TRUST ACCOUNT
CAN LAY DORMANT INDEFINITELY
DESPITE THE DEATH OF PRESUMED
DEATH OF THE BENEFICIARY. IS A
FORM OF INTANGIBLE PROPERTY
THESE ACCOUNTS FALL UNDER
STATE'S UNCLAIMED PROPERTY LAW
BUT THESE BUSINESSES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE CONSISTENT
CONTACT WITH THE OWNER OF
RECORD NOR ADEQUATELY ADDRESS
HANDLING OF THE BAND DID TRUST
ACCOUNTS. EIGHTY TO NINETY
THREE WOULD DRESS THIS BUY ONE
DECLARING THE PARTY RESPONSIBLE
FOR REPORTING ABANDON TRUST
ACCOUNTS TO ESTABLISHING
DORMANCY TRIGGERS TO SPURS. TO
PRESUME THE DEATH OF THE BAY
FISHERY AND THREE REQUIRE A
CONTACT PROTOCOL WITH THE
OWNERS OF THE UNCLAIMED PRE
NEED FUNERAL TRUST ACCOUNT. BY
DRESSING THIS LONG STANDING
ISSUE EIGHTY TWO NIGHTS FOR YOU
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND- SURVIVE
LOVED ONES PROVIDING A
CONVENIENT WAY TO LOCATE AND
CLAIM UNUSED PRE NEED FUNERAL
FUNDS. WITH ME TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
HAS BEEN FOR YOU FROM THE STATE
CONTROLLER BETTY EASE OFFICE
WHO'S A SPONSOR. OF THIS BILL
ARE STRICTLY AS PER NIGHT BUT-
THANK YOU SENATOR. PLEASE WITH
MRS. SHARE INVENTORS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
MANY ADVENTURE BUT WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE CONTROLLER BETTY
YEE I'M ALSO JOINED BY GILLIAN
NIGHT KOMMER UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
DIVISION HERE TO ANSWER A
TECHNICAL QUESTION. CONTROL
YOU'D BE THE SPONSOR A B. TWO
NINETY THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER
CALL ROOM WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL TO ENSURE CONSUMERS OUR
FAMILY OKAY THANK YOU YOU DON'T
TRUST FUND. THE THREE LINES OF
INVESTING UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
LAW AND CLARIFY WHEN AND UNDER
WHAT CONDITIONS YOU KNOW TRUST
ACCOUNT BECOME CABLE. INDUSTRY
WITH A BALL AND A LOT. BECAUSE
CURRENT MODELS PROVIDE THEIR
DIRECT OLDER OF PRETTY YOU KNOW
THE COUNTER GUARDING THE CAN.
WERE FUN YOUR CORE IT REMITTED.
CONTROLLER AS I QUITE PROUD.
STILL PROVIDE BENEFITS THE BOOK
CONSUMER AND- THAT WAS MET. THE
REQUIREMENTS. YOU KNOW THAT WAS
CLEAR. FOR WHEN TO REPORT AND
REMIT FIND AN ABANDONED ACCOUNT
AND LEAVE THEM OF LIABILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE- PROPERTY.
IN ADDITION FUNDS WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY HELD IN THE. BAND AND
ACCOUNT FOR THE RETURN OF THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. A MORE HAPPY. FOR THANK YOU
NOW LET'S FROM ANYONE. IN THE
GALLERY WHO WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IC. A WITNESS.
PLEASE PROCEED USER MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF S. C. I. CALIFORNIA
FUNERAL SERVICES AND WHY WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THE BILL WE HAVE SPENT THE-
LAST TWO YEARS WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR TO. ADDRESS
INDUSTRY CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ARE
THERE ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY SEEING NONE. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE HOURS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIX FIVE. SEEING NONE LET'S
TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCING
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL. THIS ASSEMBLY
BILL WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO- REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS ASSEMBLY
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME THE MOST MODERATE
OF THE ASSEMBLY BILL IS TWO
NINE THREE I MISSPOKE EARLIER.
THANK YOU SMB BILL TWO NINE
THREE EIGHT IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE A LINE CHEWED UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER. FIVE DEADLINE TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT OF QUEUE WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THAT'S FINE LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR MANY OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE. ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION SAYING
NONE OF THE WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO NINE THREE. I SEE NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINE THREE
WILL BEGIN. I CAN'T SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINE THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MR SURELY HAVE
KNOWN CHEWED UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE CHAMBER AND
CHAMBERS AND SEE IF I COULD
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. COLLINGS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
MEETING NINE AM THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR MAN. SENATOR
PAN DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING ON
BEHALF OF CENTER COLORADO
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NEITHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AGAIN THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
MAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BY LATE IN Q. A. B. TWO NINETY
THREE DO YOU PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
ROTH FIVE. ROSS I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA- CHILL OUT I'D BE
SORRY. BEAT FIVE BACKER. DODD
EIGHT MEN RIGHT HEY MAN I HEARD
TATO I HER TADO I'D JONES JONES
I. LEIVA. MAIN ALL RIGHT MAN HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I I'D SHOW ABOUT
OKAY UNTIL ABOUT- GUY PNI HE N.
HI BILL AS TEN VOTES WILL HOLD
THE- MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES- GIVE US ONE
MINUTE WE WILL BEGIN OPENING
THE ROLE ON THE MATTERS THAT
WE'VE HEARD. TODAY.
COLLEAGUES
ARE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE ON THE-
ON THE MATTERS WE WERE GOING TO
DO ONE CALL AND THEN WE WILL
PUT THE MATTERS BACK ON CALL WE
HAVE A. ACTUALLY WE MAY NOT
NEED TO DO THAT SO. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND OPEN THE ROLE ON THE-
THE MATTERS THAT WE'VE HANDLED
THIS MORNING I WILL ASK. THE
STAFF DIRECTOR TO ANNOUNCE THE
FINAL VOTE TALLY FOR ME PLEASE.
FILE ITEM. EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE
TO SEVEN CURRENT VOTE EIGHT
ZERO ONE DOES BACKER. DAUGHTER
FURTADO I FURTADO I JONES HELLO
TO. NOT DEVOTING. TENDS NOT
VOTING LLEVA. NINE ZERO THAT
BUT LET THOSE OUT. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS
WINE. EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
FOR A. B. FOR THIRTY FIVE SIXTY
B. FOUR EIGHTY FOUR AND TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
BACKER HI BACKER I'D DODD. A
MAN RIGHT EGGMAN I'D JONES HI
JONES I. PHOTO IS ELEVEN ZERO
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. FILE
ITEM THREE A. B. THREE FIVE SIX
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
MELINDA'S. DAUGHTER EIGHT MEN
RIGHT EIGHT MEN I'D JONES RIGHT
JONES HI LISA. PHOTO ELEVEN
ZERO THAT MATTERS OF. FILE ITEM.
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE ZERO ONE
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO
MELINDA'S. FEET DAUGHTER. JONES
HI. FIVE JONES HI LISA. MAN.%
VOTE IS NINE ZERO THAT MATTER
IS OUT. FILE ITEM FIVE AB FOUR
SIX TWO CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO
MELINDA'S BEATH I BEAT FIVE
DIED HER TADO HI HER TADO I'D
JONES HI JONES I LEAVE US. FOR
VOTE LEVIN ZERO THAT MATTER IS
OUT. PHYLUM NINE EIGHTY FIVE
THREE EIGHT CURRENT VOTE EIGHT
ZERO MELINDA'S. BEATS HI BETH I
DON HER TADO NINE FURTADO I'D
JONES HI JONES HI LISA. VOTE
LEVIN ZERO THAT MATTER IS OUT.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FOR FOUR CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO
ZERO MELINDA'S BEATS HI. BEATS
I DIED HER TADO HER TADO I'D
JONES NINE JONES I LEAVE AT.
UHHUH. PORTHLEVEN ZERO THAT
MATTER IS OUT. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO
FEATS NOT LOADING BEATS NOT
VOTING DAUGHTER. HER TADO HI
HER TADO I'D JONES VOTING.
PLEASE LEAVE AT. PHOTO. NINE
ZERO THAT MATTER IS OUT WITH.
NINE ZERO BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
TWELVE A. B. ELEVEN OH SIX
CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. B. HI BETH I DONNA.
LEAVE US. SEVEN ZERO THAT GOES
OUT. THANK YOU TO ONE MORE ONE
MORE FILE LATE IN Q. A. B. TWO
NINE THREE CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO
ZERO MELINDA'S. BACKER BACKER
II DODD. LEAVE AT. SEVEN ZERO
THE MATTER IS A- NO THANK YOU
TO ALL OF YOU PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIOS. IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD TODAY.
AGAIN THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
TODAY AND THIS COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. IS A JERK.